fans of the show know we love bud light
seltzer and you know what we love more
than bud light seltzer when they sponsor
the show they are the presenting sponsor
you know about bud light seltzer it's a
delicious hard seltzer from bud light
with no bud light in it each one is only
100 calories 5 alcohol by volume and
gluten free and now they've got the
perfect flavors for summer with the bud
light seltzer lemonade variety pack and
the brand new bud light seltzer iced tea
variety pack you can try them together
which christian did the other day and
make your ideal alcoholic arnold palmer
with a bud light seltzer iced tea and
lemonade mix pack or dive into the good
vibes of yesteryear with the retro
summer pack and retro summer icicles
there's that cherry limeade that's my
favorite flavors and you know you can
combine there's a peach ice tea and
lemonade you combine those together get
a peach arnold palmer stay tuned to hear
more about bud light seltzer's newest
offerings and a little more about us and
our summer memories later in the show
but now the show
[Music]
listeners of the show know that i often
talk about wanting to meditate guess
what i did just now what i meditated
really yeah
this is i didn't see you meditate i did
i did i have an app called ten percent a
friend of mine sent me and uh the idea
is that it
can make you
unlock certain things within you that
make you 10 happier and you're more
connected and more present and um it's
not nothing to do with the fact that we
only use 10 of our brain oh maybe that's
what it is oh maybe i misread that well
i have no idea i'm just guessing 10 hat
oh you know let me i think maybe that's
what it is how did you know that
i i didn't know it i don't know it no
i'm speculating oh okay uh i think
that's what it is i guess it doesn't
matter how is the experience no no it's
ten percent happier okay who doesn't
want to be ten percent happier i mean
you already make uh you know you rushing
to google doesn't seem like someone who
just meditated
seems like a panicky thing to do i know
look damien's facetiming should we just
no no
um that's not meta oh my god i think you
need a different program no no because
you don't seem chill at all or well i've
had coffee you need to get more present
i know i feel present now let's do the
show okay uh presently presently okay
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're presently listening to life is
short i am your very connected very calm
host justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my equally
meditative brother
christian i feel irritated now
i need meditation yeah it'll help it
helps
don't you you're not in a position to
say that it does i felt so good
afterwards i felt but my friend says you
know it's the kind of thing where you do
you'll do a bunch of times probably
until you really feel it break like
breaking through and really feeling deep
connected in the truth trust this friend
oh yeah very much so really yeah because
she walks the walk you know what i'm
saying really oh yeah she's very is she
like a guru a guru no is guru pejorative
do you know also in a girl i don't think
so can you call um
well we'll see i mean some gurus have
turned out
yeah they've turned out to be pretty
corrupt are those are those like
negative gurus or svengalis so
i don't want like any and i'm trying to
think of an example like the bhagavan
well the bhagavan i would say is a
negative guru because he that turned out
to be he abused his power yes yeah um
well why are we talking about bhagwans
and uh meditation and gurus and
meditation because our guest today is
the um he's well known as a
as a meditative person right as somebody
who promotes uh meditation and uh he's a
deep thinker
what else would you how would you say i
would say he is perhaps the leading
voice
in our society in alternative medicine
oh that's better that's nice
we can cut my stuff out no no no your
source is great
no out of respect to our guest because
he uh deserves respect he does his name
is deepak chopra i wonder if he was like
that enlightened when he was a kid like
how
centered he was i would guess that he
wasn't only because he was
a doctor of a more traditional doctor
until um the early 80s when he made a
transformation yeah alternative medicine
so i think he became i would guess that
he became enlightened and as a kid he
probably did struggle with more
traditional
um unenlightened kid things well i've
been talking a lot about this and
thinking a lot about it um that the the
perfect state to be in the ideal state
is to be
uh that of have a child-like mind return
to like our our more pure minds when we
were kids and see the world through that
lens so we talked about that today and
um we talk about many things and he was
you know he's one of those guys that's
really intimidating to sit down with
because he is
such a
deep thinker i mean he's just such a
smart person so on that one level it's
um it's a little daunting to try and
connect with him and you had never met
him no no no no i never met deepak
chopra when would i meet him i don't
know he um he does frequent uh circle
like
what would you say like uh hollywood
circles hollywood people no not that i'm
a hollywood person you're a hollywood
person well i
live i guess so right uh more so than
most people and it's very important to
note that he's got a new 21 day
meditation series that he's doing in
collaboration with alicia key hopefully
future guests hopefully it is called
activating the divine feminine the path
and you did one of these right i did one
of them but there's uh 21 of them it's
over the course of 21 days did it
activate anything any sort of feminine
qualities in you what do you think you
seem more calm i i would say that's a
feminine quality you seem more
compassionate i do you seem like you've
um yeah you have a feminine in the best
way and you're soft your skin looks
softer i don't think it's done anything
yet because it's a 21-day program and i
just dabbled i did the first one but i'm
eager to do more
um
and i think everyone else should do more
because
as you're about to learn
the feminine is a very important very
lacking thing in our society yes that i
found so interesting uh and i think it's
really important for people to hear from
the man himself about that so should we
just do it yeah i don't see why not i
know i know well because it's fun to do
this but just for us that's selfish
that's the ego we got to get out of the
ego let's get into it with we have such
a great guest today we have such a an
enlightened intelligent guest so let's
hear from him i can't wait here he is
deepak chopra life could be a dream
[Music]
technical glitches like that deepak must
be of little concern to you i would
imagine most of the things that i'm
burdened by that most of us are burdened
by are of little concern to you
uh is that safe to say do you think and
probably hard to answer yeah it's safe
to say
do not anticipate the future i do not
regret the past and i don't pay
attention to glitches
what's amazing even if they're have
happening in the present
i do if you don't notice them then
you just say let's move on that's true
so what does it take for you to get
which is what i did right now exactly i
love that i need that in my life what
does it take for you to get when do you
when does deepak chopra get frustrated
about something about a remote not
working or
do you find are those things too trivial
to you to get really worked up about i
only get frustrated uh with one thing
that is
humanity
is insane and
we are participating in that insanity if
you don't recognize the insanity of the
world right now then you are also
declaring your own insanity today today
to be human means to be responsible for
climate change for equal destruction for
poison the food chain for extinction of
species
for war for terrorism for social
injustice economic injustice
racism bigotry hatred prejudice and
every form of violence is the human
species and if that's it that's all
that's all and if you don't recognize
that then
join
you know you can either join the insane
asylum
yeah or be at peace let it do what it
does and all of us
you know either go to the bar and get
drunk or just accept
extinction so so you're advocating for
for hedonism for um
is that epicurus that would say no no i
said there are two categories of people
some yeah yeah going to the bar and some
actually
step out of this insanity to be well
adjusted
to a
insane unhealthy world is not a measure
of our sanity or our well-being so mr
chopra let's step let's assume we're not
going to the bar we're not going to take
that course stick our head in the sand
just become nihilus help me out then as
someone who wants to participate in the
world but uh doesn't want to participate
in the insanity i mean you just listed a
a a very daunting uh number of
troubles in the world that we're
responsible for like you said so how
where do we begin i guess well how do we
break through
first don't pay attention to glitches
and mine
recognize what's happening in the world
third
also know that nobody is going to change
because you tell them to change
and fourth
do not fight the darkness
bring in the light and the only way you
can bring in light is to be the change
you want to see in the world so if you
want peace in the world
you have to be peaceful peace cannot be
created by nobel peace prize winners and
angry peace activists this is a
contradiction i know a lot of peace
activists who are very angry that the
world is not at peace but they are not
in peace themselves so peace can only be
created by those who feel peace in
themselves love can only be shared by
those who have given
and received love so unless we reach a
critical mass of people
who are inherently
empathetic
compassionate loving kind
peaceful and in econom equanimity
there is no hope for the world so my
goal right now is just to share
how can we be the change we want to see
in the world that's all well i love that
quote i'm going to attribute it to you
be the change you want to see in the
world
that was deepak chopra's
okay okay well i'll say you s i'll split
credit um
you said
it
no no i'm kidding i'm okay uh dr jane
goodall not to brag but she was also on
the show we've had other uh
notable guests uh such as yourself and
she said something she she's very
similar she had a similar prescription
um and and
she advocates in a similar way
that you just mentioned which is not to
get angry and worked up but she does it
through example through love um
that great gandhi quote uh and and i i i
wonder why more people aren't listening
to great thinkers such as yourself and
dr goodall what
what what do you think the hang up is
what what is the real what are they
burdened by
so here's the
thing justin what you're addressing is
an enormous challenge for the following
reasons
everybody's mind everybody's mind is
conditioned the moment
they're given a name and an identity
we are told
this you're male you're female you're
whatever these days everybody is
included but you're given a gender
identity a racial identity an economic
identity a historical identity a
religious identity
that has been going on for thousands of
years so what we see as the world out
there
is
provisional identities with unique
stories all defending their stories and
invalidating other people's stories
right now we are
calling this the canceled culture my
story is the right version i'm
republican you're democrat your story is
worse okay and
tribalism yeah tribalism so we have a
situation
tribal minds and modern capacities
nuclear weapons cyber hacking biological
warfare
that's a devastating combination
and it's a challenging combination
because you're talking about
thousands
millennia of conditioned mind
and tribal mind
ethnocentrism bigotry hatred fear
prejudice and a mindset that says
there's me and there's the rest of the
world my story is the best yours right
is needs to be canceled it's it's
diminished it's it's if not outright
nullified it is definitely diminished
yeah i it's interesting mr trump i've
noticed because i've been spending time
with my nephews and i noticed how they
there's something really thrilling about
being around children for me because
there's an opportunity to
instruct in a way teach lessons in a way
and i'm sure you've had this with your
own kids
before some way of thinking becomes
calcified you know before it becomes
uh
to the scar tissue builds up too much um
my my nephew said he didn't like to wear
short sleeve shirts he wants to wear
long sleeve shirts and i said well why
is but no one had asked him why
uh and he's i asked him and he said well
because
foxes might bite my arm
i said foxes and i showed him a video
because i have foxes in my yard of these
friendly fox he was afraid of foxes and
there was something really exciting
about that that
i i was able to catch that um
that way of thinking before it it it
codified you know before it uh and and
is there a way to do that with adults
with with and if so how do we do that is
it is it through meditation
no children are too young how old is
your nephew he's three but he's very
bright he's like a four-year-old i'm
sure he's brighter than most of us
so no i would not teach
children meditation at the age of three
in fact i wouldn't even bother till
they're 10. yeah but
if you notice
the primary occupation of children
is play
yes yes and the primary occupation of
children is also wondered they say
where did i come from
why is this and then you give them a
reason and then they say why is that and
then you give them a reason they say why
is that and finally you have to say shut
up and go and play right
because right no
yes the main thing also you need to see
children especially before they're three
they are joyous
and playful for no reason okay yes and
yet as adults we have a phrase the
pursuit of happiness which is implying
that your fundamental condition
is
your unhappiness right so
our u.s constitution says
pursuit of happiness is the right of
every human being because that is
already assuming it's an oxygen
right
it's assuming that you're miserable
another phrase that is very kind of very
uh
an oxymoron like the pursuit of
happiness and that's called peace of
mind such a nasty morale because the
mind is never at peace right
mind is jumping from this to that etc so
when you have the wrong questions and
the wrong phrases you'll never get the
answers right you get a child
joyous for no reason yes people for no
reason curious for no reason friendly
for no reason thinking of long sleeves
and foxes only for imagination now those
are the traits we all need
to
actually be whole and to be healed we
don't need clients right
we don't even need meditation we need to
be like those kids like your nephew how
do we do that how do we get back to that
state of joyousness how do we get back
that purity you learn from your kids you
know i would i always ask my kids okay
so what's the story you're telling
yourself today
and they would come up with amazing
stories and i said okay now you've left
me at a cliff anger
how about tomorrow you you complete the
story that's great it would be amazing
in fact you listened to children's
stories my mother did that with me by
the way when i was little
child she would hold me in a lab and she
would tell me a mythical story about
gods goddesses archetypes superheroes
superheroines
and she would leave it at a cliffhanger
and she said tomorrow can you complete
the story oh that's great it doesn't
matter if it has a happy ending or a
miserable ending because some people
like to go to horror movies some like to
go to comedy some like yeah adventure
erotic costume dramas that's it yes yes
we learn from children we don't treat
children oh that's interesting well
that's great now now were there when she
was telling you these stories and you
with your kids um did you try to imbue
them with messages with social messages
or any kind of like life lessons in
those stories or just fun just
imagination that's fun and questions who
are you
who are you
what do you want
do you have meaning and purpose in your
life
what makes you excited
well those are big questions
but only the kids have the answers no i
see no no the adults don't have the
answers you know i said what is
happiness more money okay
okay or better relationship or better
health they don't understand that
happiness or joy is innate and if you
have that everything else follows as a
byproduct but
know that intuitively that's why they're
intuitive
that's why kids are creative what else
are frozen in their creativity their
algorithms only some adults are creative
and we call them artists
even artists now are thinking of how
much money will i make yes i know
not me even not me at all deepak even
though we have to take some time for our
sponsors right now i'm just kidding
but i'll give you an example okay yes
please very close to michael jackson
when he was the most creative person in
the world
and then he became so successful all he
worried about was his next hit and
thereafter the music deteriorates oh
hello yeah many things uh well yikes
that that's that there's a lesson in
that then right and i've noticed that
with other creative people that when
there's the when they're pursuing the
wrong things um is that now now how does
that happen how how does that typically
happen would you say
uh to an adult is it does it happen
during
puberty when they're socialized in
school is it is it that the ambitions of
wanting things
it happens when they're socialized in
school you know even my my own kids i
notice as soon as you oh really school
or your grandchildren as soon as they go
to school they will have to fit in right
so they end up but then today of course
it starts in education
it gets worse with time and now today
with our technology
people are confusing their selfie with
their self their sacrifice is healthy
they
sacrifice themselves for their selfie
which yes
all their uh all they're interested in
is who approves the selfie and who
invalidates the selfie i love that
they're not touch with their self that
you can attribute to me that's the i was
going to say that's gandhi though you're
stealing that from god
that's me
um i love that when you sacrifice
yourself for yourself you're school
oh that's great that's very alliterative
too that's the beginning of suffering
ah that's fascinating and
and and because there is that temptation
i feel it too just being on social media
i can feel that itch when you're not uh
oh people liked this thing i posted it
it feeds the ego yeah i mean it really
is um momentarily quite satisfying but
then then you find yourself wanting
more of that and and i you're right
we're like we're living two different
we're living in a virtual reality uh and
in many cases living more in that
reality uh what what's the prescription
for that then is it to eliminate your
social media footprint is it to just get
back to nature i use social media
perhaps
a lot
more than most but before i post
something
i ask myself is it about me or is it
going to make a difference is it going
to help somebody is it the right thing
to do and then i post if the answer yes
you post if it helps people if it's
information if it's knowledge if it's
solution if it's ideas yes but if it's a
funny bit with a nice hashtag yeah make
somebody laugh
that's great but if it's all you know
how good i look
right yeah it is you know
right very empty it has its own
that's more popular anyway so do
do do
[Music]
this segment is brought to you by bud
light seltzer's new retro summer pack
throwback stories
we were talking about old summer
memories we used to go up to this lake
every summer and when i got older i
purchased a home on this lake it's nice
we get to create new summer memories on
the lake basically for the last few days
we've been with our parents yeah i
should have just said that on a lake at
a lake house i'll add fun and a little
trying at times but people with parents
listening know that sometimes parents
can be a little trying and i'm sure we
were trying for them absolutely but you
know what helped make it less trying by
light seltzer oh yeah they're here to
bring the good vibes so they have
something now called the it's very new
and it's limited edition it's the bud
light seltzer retro summer pack so in
the pack it's a tie dye pack it's very
i've made a lot of use out of this pack
you sure have you've been also wearing
that shirt a lot that's right the pack
features three different throwback
flavors blue raspberry summer ice and
cherry limeade and summer ice is
probably my favorite because it tastes
like a melted bomb pop for the first
time ever fans can also purchase these
out of sight flavors in a new form with
bud light seltzer retro summer icicles
sorry how would you describe the flavors
out of sight get it delivered right to
your door find a retailer near you at
bud light.com
delivery or local neighborhood grocery
our convenience store or liquor store
and enjoy your bud light
summer
with us
[Music]
uh mr chopra what i'm curious what led
you from
traditional medicine to alternative was
it was it the over prescription of drugs
in western medicine what was the
catalyst for that for your department
there were many
some person and some professionals so i
trained in what is called internal
medicine
then i went on to train in endocrinology
which is the study of hormones
then i studied neuroscience and then i
got into brain chemistry so when i was
training and long before you were born i
think
um
we were discovering these molecules that
everybody is talking about serotonin
dopamine opiates oxytocin
and so
we realized very early on those of us
who were in the field that these were
molecules of emotion that you're
that whatever happened in consciousness
also had an effect in biology
so that got me personally interested in
what we call
mind-body medicine and integrative
medicine
but then something very interesting
happened at that time in the 70s when i
was training
you know it was fashionable for doctors
to smoke uh even journals would
advertise doctors smoking lucky say
lucky strike or camel oh that's right
they would advertise that the one that
the doctor most doctors smoke right and
the pharmaceutical companies would
actually sponsor that and they would
sponsor drugs also
and
one day
i had resuscitated a patient
in the hospital put a pacemaker put him
on a ventilator saved his life
in the icu and i went outside the
hospital to smoke a cigarette
oh my god
and i said i said what the
f am i doing okay yeah yeah i threw my
cigarette at that moment
wow i stopped drinking at that moment no
in one flash and i took up meditation in
that moment
why meditation why was that the the path
that you saw i traditionally from my
mother
parents from india etc that was a very
important part
which i had given up totally you know
being a resident in america all you do
is you stitch people up give them a
prescription send them home and then you
move on to the next patient so i had 30
patients outpatient 30 patients
inpatient 30 patients in the icu talking
to 100 relatives a day totally burnt out
myself so i said hey doctor heal
yourself that's how it's yes wow wow the
cigarette it was a direct connection it
was um
the cigarette i'm just trying to put
myself in your shoes that must have been
a very powerful moment i mean you know
so i decided i moved from spirits to
spirit
oh that's great i have another one that
you can another gandhi quote um i i
love that and it was and were the people
in your life thrown by this uh
revelation were they like oh deepak's
really changed right they were
particularly my professional colleagues
at
boston so there were rumors that i was
going to be fired both from my teaching
appointments at bu harvard and tufts and
also rumors that the medical practice
that
i was part of was feeling very
embarrassed by what i was saying so i
left and i went to california oh wow
they're a little bit more liberal but
things were a little better and then
these days by the way it's full circle
so i'm now teaching at three medical
schools you see ucsd harvard
mount sinai actually four medical
schools i've
gone back and become a professor of
medicine only four
actually three right now and coming
i'm back i'm back with the professional
colleagues
wow good for you do you ever miss uh
smoking is there ever a moment where you
see someone somebody think ah man it'd
be nice to have a
little no no
it's been that was you know i'm talking
about 1980 so wow that's a long long
time ago did you ever smoke weed oh
sorry deepak yeah yeah i did i did i did
everything i did yeah
we'd you name it does that help people
expand their consciousness because i've
had friends do ayahuasca i'm so curious
about ayahuasca and and i know micro
dosing is becoming a very popular uh
there is a place for all of that to
expand your
awareness and to slowly move in the
direction of ego death and these
psychedelic substances are in fact they
decrease the activity of part of your
brain called the default mode network
and the default network is that part of
your brain
that houses your ego identity so the
less
your ego identity is
dominating
the more expansion of consciousness you
have so in traditional cultures
ayahuasca and silocyben and masculine
have all been used and now there's a
resurgence of interest in do they have a
role in healing and actually i'm
participating
in the research for the public education
of what we call
psychedelics um
which have other names people depending
on your prejudice and bias yes you can
call them psychedelics or hallucinogens
or plant medicines or
sacred medicine or i like those or
whatever
whatever the least defensive is uh
because i was hoping to start my nephew
on some of those uh soon the
three-year-old um no no two-year-old
no okay uh i'll tell my i'll tell his
parents that it's you've approved and um
as i've always though wanted to try uh
meditation um i've always wanted and i
have friends who swear by it a very good
friend of mine sent me an app which i
just opened today but you have one out
now it's a 21 day meditation series
called activating the divine feminine
the path to wholeness
what what would you recommend for
someone like me a beginner and is this
is this new series something that i
could maybe find value in
yeah the new series called activating
the divine feminine
which exists in all of us it doesn't
matter with
your male female transgender lgbt
non-binary
there's a
there's a feminine energy within you in
fact the mitochondria in our body which
are the energy producing centers they
only have
women genes
every cell in your body has mitochondria
the energy powerhouses only genes are
mother genes going back to the beginning
of time
is that right yeah that is right
and so
what is the divine feminine any time you
experience beauty
anytime you experience
intuition anytime you experience
affection tenderness love
joy
empathy compassion
equanimity
and nurturing in any form you're
activating the divine feminine and we
need that right now because
as we have over kind of over
uh used our predatory masculine energy
you know that you sure have the only
solution for males is
f it or kill it
ah yeah yeah well i've i've i always
noticed that on nature shows i've been
watching a lot of nature uh progress
someone on the galapagos the other day
and and um it just really struck by how
savage um
nature you know nature's red and tooth
and claw i think gandhi also no tennyson
said that but uh
i'll say you said it but um it strikes
me that you're right that the males in
all of those are um you're right either
effing or
effing
yeah fighting or
fighting or um making love
fornication and feed
yes so how so we're too mad so you would
say that this culture is too masculine
it's safe to say the whole
the whole world culture is masculine not
just this culture
we started out as hunter-gatherers so we
needed to be masculine right in the age
of agriculture which is so you know
hunter gatherer is going back 40 000
years
agriculture goes back only 12 000 years
so as soon as the agricultural age came
animals got domesticated we had the
emergence of a few matriarchal societies
but masculine energy still dominated and
then we had the world of science and
technology where again the masculine
energy says how can i create nuclear
bombs how can i create biological
warfare how can i create cyber hacking
and on and on you know right but right
same technologies if you bring feminine
energy
there is redemption and we need that
right now to save humanity
wow wow i'm so glad our listeners are
getting i'm so glad i'm listening to you
uh i don't want to speak for all of our
listeners but
what what a healthy beautiful what a
beautiful prescription for
a change for how to make real change uh
so we get in touch with our how would so
through meditation how does that enable
one to get in touch with this divine
feminine what's the process like you
know we have this on the app the chopra
app all you have to do is go chopra.com
and you've got this app too so you know
many years ago i i officiated at the
wedding ceremony of alicia keys and we
have the same very good friends
and alicia to me personifies in many
ways the qualities of the divine
feminine in the art and the music and
her dance and the way she yeah this is
herself in her embrace of
multiculturalism she embodies yes and
classically the divine feminine all
traditions has seven classical themes
okay okay so let me mention the greek uh
versions but they're true of every
tradition in the world okay era is the
goddess that represents power but not
power over
others of self-esteem number one
aphrodite
represents sexuality beauty love
athena represents knowledge and wisdom
artemis represents a connection to
nature
persephone represents the healer and the
alchemist
and hestia represents the homemaker
now put these all
together these themes
imagine a world of leadership that
represented these themes oh my god you
would have a completely different world
oh yes i mean if these were my friend
calls them pillars like pillars of one's
life and if these were the pillars of
our society i mean you're right i mean
what a
what a different place we would live in
one of um especially with that i don't
know how you get aphrodite under control
um
in the context of love meaning beauty
intuition
will transcend every physical sexual
experience you have and make it holy and
sacred
wow
wow and then you get to be sting
you know sting has that those
hours long sessions of um
uh you know i forget what it's called
transcendental it's not transcendental
meditation is it it's not a string is a
father meditation his wife both are good
friends and true amazing people yes
trudy yes um uh well so anyone can go to
so this is chopra.com this is how you
get the 21 day meditation series
it's free it's available to everyone who
checks in
and so with something like when you
officiated alicia key's wedding how does
that happen how does somebody reach out
to you
to to
do a surface like that
alicia did it very cleverly she said can
i meet you i'll be happy to come
wherever you are
okay then some people joined her and
they i met them and she said would you
do this for me how could i refuse
oh yeah i became a very good friendship
um that's wonderful you you and is she
had she been meditating meditating
before the long-term practitioner
meditation ah okay
how long was george harrison as um
as were the beatles as oh yes boys as
were some of the greatest artists i've
known they're all friends by the way oh
george harrison is my favorite i got to
play him in a movie not to brag um
because that's ego based bragging is ego
based why would i do that
um i want to hear a good story about
george
i sure do so here we are in india
and we are
going to a hotel at the taj in mumbai
and there's a whole crowd out there and
george says oh my god you can never
escape a crowd i said why don't you go
through the back door i go through the
front door
and so i went through the crowd
the crowd was not for george it was for
prince charles and george was very upset
that's really funny so he was hoping to
avoid it and then he got there's a
lesson in there right yeah he was very
sad
for me i said no
oh that's funny i heard he was really
funny a very funny person ever
everything i've seen the moment you
started to speak to him he was using
what the conversation to create lyrics
in his mind
wow wow incredible i just read that he
had written something that one of my
favorite songs and he he doubted himself
so much in his songwriting skills that
he was all set to give it to joe cocker
to record um and we would have been
without that beautiful rendition of
something um you know if you have time
after this conversation download a song
of his called
the rising sun which
was published after his death oh yes i
was at his house when
we went and uh created the lyrics based
on my book quantum healing check it out
oh wow i will the rising sun uh there's
too much
i i'm overwhelmed right now i'm starting
to get a little panicky i need i need to
meditate briefly because there's too
much to talk to you about and we have
very little time um i i want to ask you
about uh your your ideas on human aging
that you call it fluid and changeable
what do you mean by that and do you
believe consciousness is is more
important than matter you've said that
and you've also said
you think you'll live to be well past a
hundred i'm so curious about this
okay so there's biological aging there's
chronological aging there's
psychological aging and there's
non-aging as a spirit
there are all these different categories
of aging i'm 75 going to be 75. my
biological markers are right now under
40. so
i can outdo anyone in their 40s
physically really like in a race in
strength endurance mental physical
capacity really you look great i got to
tell you people are this is no one's
going to see this they were just
listening you are aging is
for some
period of time reversible as for 100 i
will choose when i die in meditation i'm
not expecting to die through a disease
or whatever if if this humanity
continues this insane course i may
choose to take the big meditation
earlier instead of going to the bar i
may take it early
but how do you what do you mean by that
i'll ch i don't expect no one expects to
die from disease but how
right now most people die from disease
nobody understands what is the cause of
death you say stroke or heart disease
right or cancer or something right
that does doesn't mean that aging should
necessarily
be accompanied by disease although it is
accompanied by disease in the vast
majority of people if you understand
genetics you'll understand that less
than five percent
of disease related gene mutations are
fully penetrant the rest are influenced
by lifestyle that includes sleep
management stress exercise mind-body
coordination
healthy emotions balancing your
biological rhythms changing the activity
of a microbiome and being in touch
with nature if you pay attention to all
these you will reverse for a time the
biological markers of aging we just
published a study on meditation one week
retweet the levels of the enzyme
telomerase went up by 40 and the study
was done in collaboration with the nobel
laureate who won the nobel prize for
just that discovering that enzyme
telomerase she ended up writing a book
called the telomere effect so i believe
if you understand that the body is not
made of matter it's not made of energy
it's not made of information it's made
of consciousness then you're not set
so
deep oh god you make it sound so simple
and easy but of course it starts with i
think a huge ingredient sounds like it
is meditation and and eating properly
like eating the right things putting
these good things in your body um
and i keep going back to that moment you
have the epiphany uh how drastically did
you change your lifestyle after you put
out that cigarette and had that uh
revelation
slowly i mean it didn't happen overnight
but in the last i'd say 15 years
i haven't experienced what people call
stress
wow
okay so
very joyful last 15 years
that's enough for me it doesn't matter
how long you live lest you live and
you're joyful and you know if i close my
uh eyes i don't feel a body
because wow it's pure consciousness
oh my god so what you and so you were
able to just clear your head when you
close your mind because everyone is
familiar with this uh is the the you
know the hamster wheel in the head how
do how have you come to
quiet those those voices
to stop the hamster wheel being in the
process justin nothing is overnight but
you know why we realized that as soon as
you close your eyes you become aware
that you're telling a story to yourself
but also you become aware that most of
the stories about what can go wrong and
what did i regret and how can i have a
better future and then that story which
in eastern wisdom traditions
is called karma karma is just your
personal story
and that projects as the body so if
you're
i ask you right now to think of
something really stressful somebody was
mean to you then close your eyes and
feel your body
mm-hmm how does it feel
uh tight and uh not good okay now think
of falling in love
yeah oh i [ __ ] feel
i mean
just effortless and and light okay so
now that there you are your body is the
projection of your internal dialogue
karmic baggage
yeah this is the karmic body it's also
referred to as the pain and pleasure
body but behind this is the body of
bliss of joy
is when you bypass
the secret passages the dark alleys and
the ghost-filled attics of your
conditioned mind
of the past and then now also you had
mentioned earlier not well you don't
dwell on the future no i don't passion
no regret no resistance just this moment
as it is
wow wow what was that that's also called
presence
presence yes which would help me as an
actor too because that's
in fact cornerstone if you are a method
actor and some great actors were method
actors ben kinsman for example rich yes
gandhi gandhi
yeah so when ben kingsley became
acting as gandhi
for the entire year he adopted the
lifestyle of gandhi
really and he was present to that he
didn't smoke he didn't drink he was even
celibate
for the oh my god
you know that
sorry deepak it's it's so interesting
you said that cause a friend of mine
told me a story about sir ben kingsley
they were flying
they had done a movie together and they
were flying somewhere to promote it it
was an eight-hour flight
and anna ferris my dear friend also uh
has a wonderful podcast uh she said that
ben kingsley and i'll never forget this
she said he just sat
and i said what do you mean he he didn't
watch movies he didn't read anything
nope he sat did he sleep no he sat and
stared ahead for eight hours
uh and that's to you is probably not
noteworthy but i couldn't get over it
that's present right right
and great actors even richard burton
with all his problem
baggage yeah he had presence
when he was acting a role
that's what he was
okay he became that
that's
the secret of all great actors
this is fascinating i it's killing me
that we have so little time i and this
is too big a question to answer quickly
maybe but um
of course i i dwell on the after talk
about dwelling and thinking about the
future i think about death a lot in the
afterlife and um boy do i need your
meditation uh what do you think happens
to people when they die do you do you
believe in a form of an afterlife
death is based on a false construct and
a false identity
so it is a construct nothing happens to
you when you die let me give you an
example you're in the room right now
right
and i'm in a different room right
right we're zooming and uh yeah and we
are in cyber space
let's say
the
walls of the room collapse or the
connection is cut off
what happens to you you're still there
but i'm not seeing you anymore and
you're not seeing me anymore so this
space is never affected because it was
never born it never died
and your true self was never born it
never dies you take a vacation called a
person which is not you the person is a
projection of you it's your conditioned
mind that is projecting as a changing
identity you say i am my body which one
fertilized egg zygote embryo infant
toddler baby so when you die which one
dies your your embryo has already died
your infant has already died in every
moment every thought is born it dies
every emotion is born it dies every
perception is done it dies your body is
dying right now and being born right now
and if it forgets to die
then that you get cancer you know
apoptosis is programmed cellular death
when cells don't die they become
cancerous so
death is built into the program for life
the opposite of life is not death the
opposite of life
has no opposite birth is the opposite of
death
and death is the opposite of birth and
birth and death are the continuum of
life
and once you recognize that and get in
touch with your timeless being you
realize
that you will never die because you were
never born
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
i keep talking about one dream with
people because i keep showing off the
things i'm learning on onedrive we
should spell it so it's w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
one-dream it's a streaming service that
has all of these different programs
these very educational programs you can
explore thousands of hours literally
thousands of hours of fascinating video
and audio content documentaries
tutorials travelogues and more i took a
course called pioneering skills for
everyone modern homesteading where i
learned how to pickle okay so fun and
delicious it's so easy to make your own
pickles i've also been taking learning
spanish i'm taking from one of the
greatest spanish teachers he's got it's
such an impressive resume i don't i
don't want to bore you with it but trust
me uh it's been a great way to
supplement my spanish learning on
another app that i don't want to mention
we know you're going to love wondering
as much as we do so use our special url
so that they know we sent you go now to
one dream dot com slash long and for a
limited time sign up and you'll get a
free month trial of unlimited access oh
try it out it's a good time to try it
too because it's summer break maybe some
of you are sitting around wanting to do
something maybe you want to grill you
want to get better at grilling and
impress some friends that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash long
again one dream dot com slash long
sign up today
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far
follow harsh reality the story of miriam
rivera on apple podcast amazon music or
you can listen early and add free by
joining wondering plus in apple podcasts
or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
what is your most i can't believe i'm
asking you this what is your most
commonly used emoji deepak if you if you
happen to text people this
this the prayer hands make sense i am i
honor the sacred in you
as i honor the sacred in me
oh beautiful if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play
um i would play probably um
lying still and see who can uh last
longer
i you probably win uh you definitely
beat me uh if you could have uh one
snack food for the rest of your life
your guilty pleasure and not even guilt
i don't think you experience guilt but a
pleasure that you really enjoy from
eating chocolate
chocolate in in any particular form all
forms chocolate is oxytocin it's the
pleasure molecule
uh and what is your do you have a movie
that you were really excited to share
with your maybe gandhi that you were
excited to share with your kids actually
you should watch this movie it's called
lost horizon it's about never aging
and it was produced in the 40s it's in
black and white and okay it inspired me
to understand that why you don't need to
age
oh great i
okay say no more clinton is the author
okay lost horizon um and
have you ever been to a
a karaoke bar i have in japan you have
men
oh yes i love the japanese karaoke bars
do you remember what you sang or
something that you would want to sing if
you were to go back let it be
ah
when i find myself and oh beautiful uh
no that's not let it be yeah let it be
um at george
um
what's your uh and who do you remember
having a crush on a celebrity when you
were a kid when you were growing up
you wouldn't recognize them they were
bollywood stars bollywood stars when did
you come over here how long were you
there
i went to india immediately after
medical school so 23.
and i've lived in america more than in
india and okay you know i don't relate
to indians that much right right um
are people always coming up to you and
just saying i'm sure they of course they
recognize you and do they well what is
the thing they most often say do they
want they must want help they must want
very interesting they don't recognize me
they recognize my voice now oh cause i'm
all over the place in these audios in
podcast
so they don't recognize me but they
recognize the voice and they just
well you know we live in a selfie
culture so they wanted all they want is
a selfie oh of course um if you had to
get a tattoo where would you what would
you get do you think
if i would to get a tattoo it would
probably and i haven't although i've
thought about it
it would all probably be the mantra um
and it would be in my heart
beautiful uh and what is your favorite
fruit
if you could pick any fruit changes but
these days i'm focusing on berries and
cherries of all kinds because the
highest by the way they had the highest
concentration of
of antioxidants and what are called
phytochemicals for healing that's a
great industry every cherry anything
that ends with the berry and the cherry
a great endorsement um who do you who
would you want to play you in your
biopic in the deepak chopra story i
would like
me to be forgotten and just people would
say there's some fragrance there but
it's diminishing
i would rather be forgotten a pleasing
fragrance hopefully yeah um and
do you ever watch the simpsons and if so
who was your favorite character i did
watch the simpsons and i did enjoy it
all
during the years i can't say new it was
a beautiful
way to express diversity and humor
contribution and paradox and ambiguity
all the things that make us interesting
instead of self-righteous morality which
makes us so
so uh
such boring no cunning
hypocrites yes yes greatest morality
stunning hypocrisy
um
do you prefer dogs or cats
neither neither uh do you have any pets
at all any animals
and so i'm tolerant of dogs okay all
right uh the beetle i think you i may
know this the beatles are the rolling
stones if you had to choose one oh
beetles
personal relationship with them of
course and you might know the rolling
stones too and i love them
and you mentioned let it be uh if you
were to go out somewhere now and what's
this beatles song that you'd really love
to hear that that that makes you just
feel even more joyous than you are well
right now everybody's talking about uh
the psychedelic revolution so i'd say
lucy in the sky with that oh yes um
beautiful yeah and
you're a vegetarian right you're a vegan
yeah okay um
what would be if you were having
summer's coming up that their cookouts
happening what would what would be a
great vegan option at a cookout for
somebody like me who's dabbling
a salad with maximum diversity of
plant-based foods
wonderful i'm gonna do it in your honor
and i can't thank you enough i'm doing
your favorite emoji thank you thank you
deepak this has been so enlightening and
interesting lovely thank you thank you
thank you
okay so
so that just happened it just happened
i didn't want to do it why
because it you don't want to be
offensive well but see now i'm wondering
if that would be offensive because
wouldn't it be more offensive to not do
it because i often try to do an
impression of a lot of our guests and
why shouldn't i attempt to do one of him
you know it's it's it's a specific to
him it would be but maybe it would sound
just like a general offensive
indian accent when a white person
doesn't well i think what's fresh in my
brain is
that um hank azaria
had
trying to get him on the show by the way
everyone yes hank azaria was the
longtime voice of a poo on the simpsons
and that has since been um deemed
problematic and he's no longer the the
voice and he's apologized um many times
over for the cultural appropriation
but i would say that's that might be
different only because
i think what's offensive about that is
that apu was um
the the uh stereotypical very type of a
guy who works in a like a 7 11
yes exactly um
whereas
you doing deepak chopra's voice you're
not stereotyping him as
someone a great thinker or
you know someone who's in touch with
their inner consciousness or something
that's true that's true but it still
might be perceived that way it might be
and best not to even attend yeah i'm
glad you didn't yeah thanks i noticed
that you called him i mean you at a
certain point you got a little more
familiar with him and you called him
yeah which is fine it's his name
he called you justin yeah he had kind of
although you're not worthy of the same
level of respect as he is obviously i
don't expect him to call me mr long but
you did call him mr chopper and i
wondered if he might have been irked by
that because he's a doctor oh my god
that's right it's almost like you don't
think of him as a doctor no because he's
an alternative yes and he's still a
doctor right i do you mean do you
would do he hasn't gotten dis not
disbarred or did he just bar himself or
whatever the terms lose your life did he
he didn't lose his life is he so
anti-western medicine that he doesn't
identify with that label exactly yeah
maybe i should have asked him that oh i
know
i mean you know i'm just speculating he
didn't bristle or anything when no said
mr chopra or when i said deepak i don't
think no
although mr chopra you know i think part
of it is i've got this thing about mr
doctor because our father yes is
not a medical doctor but uh he has a
doctor of philosophy yeah and so he was
dr long is dr long you both have to have
a heightened awareness of the prefix
doctor because of your father and he
really preferred um
being called dr long instead of mr law
yeah it was like respect a little
problematic for him when people called
him mr yes he would bristle a little bit
a little bit yeah well i get it because
he's on the one hand it's like who cares
you know because i'm not a die i didn't
go through that on the other hand he
went through a lot of that exactly i
know i get it well i know i'm trying to
think of an example i don't get it well
an ego based because it is ego based i
mean let's face it uh it well you can
make that argument but you could also
make the case that
it's factual to call him yeah doctor law
yeah but it's not something that
is inappropriate if you don't i mean it
shouldn't be i don't think is it
analogous to sir kingsley not calling
someone who's been knighted sir or a
dame uh-huh or uh queen victor if you
met queen elizabeth oh i think that's
different elizabeth royalty no you
wouldn't call it lizzy
you might but uh but but at night like
ben kingsley sir i mean you wouldn't if
you got to know him sure i haven't even
known trying to think if i've ever met a
knight
i was this is arrogant i was about to
say i must have met a knight but it's
arrogant to think like why would i
forget a knight you never met ben
kingsley or um i think i met elton john
briefly oh really is he he's not yeah
yeah sir ellen johnson i need to think
of him as a knight
he is you know like but now but i'm
thinking a night like a nebulous night
medieval night like atlantis or
gwenevere
why don't you eat before i should always
i should can i distribute your greening
no
um speaking of ben kingsley
i
he didn't eat for a long time i should
be able to that's true i can't believe
you just compared yourself to gandhi no
i'm no and just in that they or the
method acting i mean the method acting i
was interested in the audacity i didn't
know that ben king either lived like
gandhi for a year and the craziest part
was celibate for a year yeah doesn't it
make you think
that if he enjoyed that year and he felt
healthy i'm sure he did i'm sure
probably felt amazing i wonder why i
didn't keep up with the gandhi lifestyle
wow the celibate thing probably would
have been tough or not or or it like
freed him in a way ben kingsley
i don't know i we should have him on and
ask him about that uh i could have
listened to that all day you teasing him
about who what what quotes
that contributed to him that was my
favorite
it was my favorite you're like you're
like that's yours right he's like no
that's not that's god i think he started
to get a little irked by it you think i
he's maybe not he was pretty playful
he was yeah he had a he had a like a
cherubic sense of play which makes sense
considering the whole uh idea of
reconnecting to the child like brain
right it did remind me a little bit uh
as you mentioned of the jane goodall
interview yes yes in the especially his
activism yeah in that
he he talks about
um
if you want there to be peace in the
world if you want there to be harmony in
the world
you need to live peacefully and
harmoniously you can't scream at people
on social media it reminded me again of
how pervasive i know that is now on
social media
people you see it all the time these
like duke quote-unquote do-gooders
screaming at people to be better and
kinder and more compassionate you know
in such an aggressive way
be [ __ ] better be [ __ ]
compassionate it's crazy without any
compassion without any love i know it is
crazy it's i i see the antithesis of
that too all the time
with a lot of actors do that yeah you
know these virtue signaling uh a lot of
them yeah it's and it's to feed the ego
really because oftentimes i notice it's
done without any real prescription it's
just like this is what's wrong and this
is what's bad and shame on you i mean
it's all coming from this place of real
like darkness like hostility without any
prescription like here's how we can make
it better it was pretty daunting when he
rattled off all the problems with the
world i know in such a [ __ ] such a
casual way yeah
it's overwhelming i mean it really is
like he as smart as he is as
wise as he is
he doesn't have you know
anywhere close to a prescription there's
just too many
uh problems but i think
what he does have is
a sense of perspective that
that the first step has to be
acknowledging
that
these problems exist yep you know and
and and he says if you don't then you're
participating in this insanity so yeah
yeah that was interesting and that it
starts from within i like that he talked
about what you can control i mean that's
where meditation comes into play uh
being mindful of your own
you know limitations and
your own deficiencies um
and and how much your ego comes into
play i think that's the whole idea with
meditation that's what i'm excited about
is separating yourself from from the ego
yeah he he said that you know some
people
um experience like feel all these
problems it feels like the weight of the
world is on them and they go to the bar
and drink
when he said that i've done that i've
had not only have i done that but i
completely understand
why people would do that yeah there's so
much there's so many problems that it
like i know you begin to deal with them
in a healthy way it's overwhelming seems
overwhelming sometimes yeah sometimes
it's easier to and that's why with
social media it's easy i find myself
just checking out it's easier to check
out and also i don't think has to be one
or the other it doesn't have to be right
purely altruistic every social media
post it's i think it's okay if it makes
you feel good too well i wondered that
about him like i wondered if
what his connection to his ego is that's
the the interesting thing about a guy
like that who really promotes this this
sense this idea of like separating from
the ego but then you think like well
you know the reality is he does have a
huge following huge social media
following yeah he makes money and a huge
amount of money money yeah i mean
there's no denying that it's difficult
to get around that because there's a
there's a real beauty in his message of
course in compassion and and um
and everything he talked about the the
ego and the afterlife and all of that
death death that death doesn't really
exist um yes
if we're conscious interesting it's
interesting i mean it's definitely like
he doesn't want to be remembered a
unique perspective well it's also um for
a guy who
doesn't want to be remembered he does a
lot of self-promotion right that's the
other that's what i mean like but maybe
he would say that
i don't want to be remembered after i'm
gone
even though he would say that i'm not
gone maybe right um but he doesn't want
to be remembered but in the present he
wants to be heard from yeah and he would
probably say well and the president i
want to be heard from
because i can help people
yeah it's hard that's true which is a
net positive right
but it is hard to reconcile some of
those
inherent contradictions even the time
one he joked about it but you know time
is a construct there's there is no time
and we have to not participate in it and
certainly be beholden to it i love that
idea but then he was like there's five
minutes left right that's right right
and in the beginning it was funny
because his microphone wasn't working um
or he was sounded very faint and mish
our intrepid producer was trying
executive producer senior producer right
no no i intrepid i meant intrepid's
senior producer yeah okay um but you you
can't mis-title her too
deep and meech um but i said
they were trying to figure out the
microphone thing and he said well you
know don't worry about like it's trivial
like these things are
but it was like like i'm not concerned
with these trivialities it's like the
technical thing but it's like well
there's a reality we want to be able to
hear you you know i i i
we were concerned with hearing him
because that's why obviously he was
there uh but it's it was funny for
because that's i think you reach a point
when you're as um when you've meditated
so long when you're as in touch with
your own consciousness i guess or you're
as mindful as he is i guess those things
maybe do seem trivial and
time becomes
you know not as bright
intrusive a thing in his defense when he
said okay they're five minutes left it
was right after you panicked and asked
him like the most involved impossible
question
you're like okay oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i know
okay um how do you feel about matter of
conscience consciousness time right now
aging no you're like the afterlife and
yeah and he was like okay let me try to
sum this up and like unpack 30 seconds
fever question uh it was a fever
question yeah but i understand there's
some there's so much to talk to him i
know and 45 minutes just doesn't seem
like enough i know i know so i i kind of
want to like
it we'll read more of his stuff and
and or follow him around and just hear
him spouting
his theories everything he was saying
was interesting i thought and but it was
too dense it was dense yeah i know i
know but i think if you're around that
enough
you would um you would absorb it you
know yeah it felt more like um
he was instructing and and it was it was
at such a clip and it was that kind of
stuff i remember taking a a hegel
seminar um in in in college and it was
so it was such dense stuff it was uh we
would only get through like a page a
class it was like a three four hour
class you know that kind of stuff that
you really need to
sit with and
meditate on ruminate on i would say
hegel was
way more dense than what um deepak
chopra oh yeah because it also had so
much to do with math i mean it was all
numerical based which i i have a hard
time with uh but it was really yeah i
mean deepak yes certainly not
as tough but but he was trying to do it
i mean i i wanted to absorb as much as
possible and but there was just not
enough time right uh he very casually
brought up michael jackson which i
thought was interesting yeah that was uh
um without yeah you know um
addressing the elephant in the room no
that was disarming it was yeah i could
tell you were um very surprised
you were like oh okay uh and he said but
his point was that
um his career
took uh a downward turn once he became
you know fixated on the money and the
commercial success
and the ego and he stopped making it he
and he's i think he actually said things
started to deteriorate for me and you
were like oh that's not the only thing
that deteriorated yep
world that was a weird position to be in
because um
i don't think you did anything wrong no
no i don't feel that way but it is uh
socially
tricky because um sure i'm talking to
somebody who knew him well and in fact
and this person that you're talking
about is extremely problematic and he
did right awful things awful things yeah
and so how do you
it's an interesting
you also don't want to be disrespectful
wait a minute you were not allowed to
talk no i know i know i want him to feel
free to speak openly i mean it's deepak
chopra but he is friends with these um
huge musicians uh
living and dead he talked about george
harrison
and
you um oh man that was exciting when you
asked him what beatles song
he would uh he'd like to hear
and he said let it be you got really
excited because you know there are a lot
of points in the conversation where he
was talking and you were talking you
weren't necessarily connecting around
the same page about something but it but
i felt this happened you're on the same
page he said a song that you love
that you are
that you can really identify like
connect to there's a moment where i
could like be with it was a real moment
of like yes here's some common ground
and you awkwardly
started singing let it be you were like
yes when i found myself in times of
trouble
and i got shivers all over my body like
awkward shivers all over my body
yes
do you remember we used to call that up
i saw you
listen to it and you had like you were
so like embarrassed to be in a room with
me you like put your shirt over your
face
remember we used to call it douche
chills
i mean i think i got that from bill burr
oh oh yeah maybe friend of the show
friend of the show yeah yeah when when
somebody does something so dude i'm also
like a tribute i'm i'm conscious to
attribute quotes to the right people
i know
i know i
uh that was funny that was fun
but he does he was proud of um his
selfie it's a good quote that is a good
quote i'm forgetting he said it twice
yeah if i i quoted myself the other day
with i was talking to my neighbor mick i
was so proud of this quote mick's
helping me out with my little cabin i'm
getting um you know i'm doing some work
on it and
and he said uh he was offering
suggestions about how to fix it up and
you know put the rail on the porch and
you should get this kind of storm door
he said
just make sure this is what you want and
it's not me talking you into it but i
think you'll like it and i said
it's okay to be tucked into something if
you respect the authority and wisdom of
the person doing the talking definitely
you wrote that and i wrote my name
justin long
oh my god that's a joke and he said look
his response too much bs
and i said oh and i attributed that
quote to him that's funny uh yeah he was
but he it's a good quote when you have a
good quote do you ever say something
that you're like proud of
uh yeah but i don't know if i've ever
written it down as a joke
well sort of as a joker seriously i
don't think i've ever done that huh
maybe i have i've written down quotes of
yours that are really funny you have
yeah yeah let's see here i try to think
of funny names for
my memoirs or my autobiography
this is uh you you
about david bowie being from another
planet you said no he wasn't he was just
a pretty bisexual
are these our can we use any of these
for what i don't know my tombstone you
said uh after i farted you once said um
i quoted you here it smells like you
have cholera or something it's gonna
stick to my clothes
that's pretty funny and gross
all right let's read it okay okay
are you realizing how far you are from
deepak chopra i'm realizing how far this
conversation has gone from talking about
deepak chopin right now he's talking
about you farting
speaking of that you reminded me i
admire your restraint in not doing um
puns on his name oh yeah no no no i
thought you were going to be like
children troy rolling in the deepak with
you
okay i was really ready for a lot of
those yeah no i was i wanted to be
respectful
well mission accomplished yeah oh thanks
here we go this is from chris
michelle
m-i-c-h-e-l i know that because that's
how sony michelle spells his nose thing
about sonny michelle you don't bother to
think about a sony michelle when you
think about the name michelle
okay
subject subject
what if from a digital nomad hmm
i'm a digital nomad i live in an rv and
travel across america cool people like
you well more like technology live in an
rv no spend time in one yeah but not
that much time wow that's cool
additional nomad
and i love the podcast well that must be
a big a part of you know if you're a
digital nomad you probably listen to a
lot of podcasts i imagine um back to
chris
and i love the podcast i repeated that
especially the what-if section and while
i was sitting by the fire i thought of
this how cool
what if you had an mri and the doctor
said you had a tumor and had two choices
one
leave the tumor but only have five years
to live or two
remove the tumor but have a completely
different personality hmm
we've we've talked about that
so far yeah we have i'm trying to
remember it's like knowing um if if you
can know when and how you're going to
die would you want to know that yeah but
this is different this is more like a
house set in your existence how how much
a part of your existence and the joy of
your existence is your personality when
deepak chopra would say what he would
say it's not gonna if you if you don't
think you are you can the tumor is only
the result of
being aware like having too much
awareness of death is that i don't know
i didn't quite get that
i didn't get a lot of what he was saying
i'll be honest it was a lot yeah it
requires definitely a second reading
yeah a deep accurate dive yes
um uh you know what
um i think it depends what you mean by a
different a totally different
personality completely if that means
i'm not me anymore you don't remember
who i don't know who i am like i'm a
different person
yeah exactly then i would choose the
five years yeah
it's not that i wouldn't want to be
someone else or i wouldn't want to be a
different personality um
it wouldn't be
i wouldn't be aware of
myself yeah so i'd rather have five more
years of me of awareness of my life yeah
well let me ask you this then if you if
you chose that one which i think i would
too leave the tumor but only have five
years to live that's still five years
then you could really live live i mean
what would you do with that what's the
first what are the first few things you
would do
uh first few things i would do
yeah
um
[Music]
i don't know i i i guess i would
i don't know if five years is a long
time if you have an idea you have a
month yeah it's different now you take
more extreme chances
but five years is like you know what i
think i would live i would keep on
living the way i'm living yeah this
year's for the first like three years so
you've really just watched more tv
i think that's what i do
you know what i would do is um i would
get a
ticket for like to go all over the world
you know right away um i think so like i
want to see
as many places as i can you also have
more means than i do that's true
so
to get a first class ticket
all around the world is would be a
little tricky yeah i know then i would
um if i had a lover uh someone i really
loved i would um
have a kid right away you would yeah
huh
that seems a little selfish to me
yeah but i'd like to the experience and
i'd like to be oh would you but i'd like
to pass that what about the kid well the
kid would be the kid is guaranteed to
have their father die when he's four
that's true come on he'd be left a lot
of uh money to do with what he wanted
okay
or they okay but that's still um they
would know for sure they'd be losing
their father ah that is true that'd be
real that's a moral conundrum especially
at the age of like four yes that's a
tough age i didn't think about i thought
about it too selfishly very much that's
not a very deep way to think no
but then again like you're right deepak
would say see i know this is i don't
think you die maybe offensive but i feel
that way when really really old men like
steve martin yeah i don't want to say
that because i like steve martin a lot i
love stephen but when they have kids at
like 70. yeah but steve martin still
seems like
like youthful and puckish he seems like
he's
in touch with that kind of but you're
just setting a child for tragedy at a
pretty early age yeah but not if you
look at death the way deepak does which
is that it's not
the end of anything it's not there's no
you know it's not it's everyone's dying
agreed but if you also listen to what
deepak says about children
um for them they're pure and it's all
about play and curiosity and asking
questions
and until what he said he said until
they're 10 they shouldn't even think
about meditating it's just innocence
so
if you're talking about me by now i know
if you're talking about a child
losing a parent and no like setting them
up for a situation where they're
definitely going to lose a parent well i
think that's hard to do to a kid well
how about this if you knew that you were
gonna die and you knew at
the age of your kid was let's say if i
do my timeline it's four the kid's gonna
be four
can't you start can't you be more
conscientious of how you introduce the
idea of death and of of that
impermanence you can i think you'd have
to yeah but it's still a very tricky
thing to do i know and it's i guess it's
arrogant too to think like well i i will
have endowed a child with some of my own
you know also it's funny you're saying
this now because you're the same person
who a couple months ago i remember
having a conversation with you about
this where you said you have no real
desire to pass on your
like your dna i don't i don't and you'd
be fine adopting or yeah
i would but now it sounds like no you're
so into passing on your dna that you
just want to like pass it on and then
leave oh no it's not it's not my dna i i
don't i mean
if legacy it's your legacy um it's
i guess part of it is that i guess it's
partly maybe you just don't know
also how do you feel maybe i don't know
i have somebody i'm thinking about like
the thing that really scares me and the
thing i think about is like the final
moments you know having
the thing that's what i think about a
lot is having somebody to
leave like leaving the world like having
somebody in your eyes you there will be
something that you take in a final
image or feeling or that's all for you i
know leaving a child behind
doesn't do anything
for you at that point
i know that's true
i guess it's the experience wanting the
experience of like
but that all seems selfish now then it's
also ego if you know you're gonna die in
five years you're gonna want to put all
that work in i know raising a kid you're
right and then not get to you're right
reap the rewards oh my god you're right
and it's just like you're gonna do all
the work and then leave you might as
well just experience the world in a
selfish way right and like you know do
good things for people obviously
but i i would want more freedom if i
knew i only had five years that's true
that's true it's a good point god i feel
like that's been happening a lot where i
don't think uh deeply enough about
deepak lee enough about something
and then have my mind change that's nice
well you're open to having your mind
change that's good yeah i guess so
that's one way of looking at it or i'm
fickle and maybe it's good that my
mind's a little malleable yeah
i can i'm like your uh like puppet
master oh my god you could convince me
of anything now
uh that's crazy
um
well thank you so much chris that was um
and also how cool living out there what
i wonder what that's like to be a
digital nomad i never heard that term
and you guys would like to write into
the show our email address is life is
short at wondery.com and thank you again
to
the iconic
deepak chopra he was discovered he was
made famous by uh chopra winfrey
hopefully a future guest chokeslayer she
really has the uh midas touch that oprah
that's sure that what an understatement
yeah although sometimes she gets
an understatement midas
that's true that's a big statement
king midas right what what my deal he
touched things they turned to gold yeah
i think it's a it was a bad thing
it was right yeah yeah it's like i think
midas touch might be pejorative and if
it is
i certainly take it back because i only
have positive feelings about oprah
winfrey yeah me too oh she's
i mean she's uh talk about icons and
everyone should um
do deepak chopra's meditation yeah or
any meditation 21-day meditation that he
does with um alicia keys uh sounds
really not yeah get in touch with the
divine feminine i loved all that stuff
he was it makes so much sense you know i
i hope the world becomes more feminine
and um
also the future is female future is yeah
hopefully so justin is going to go
meditate more and maybe eat a sandwich
first the sandwich i think it might pass
out if i try to meditate on an empty
stomach that's a gandhi quote no it's
not uh anyway uh come up with some good
quotes and and write in to life is short
onedrive.com hey thanks for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
here we go gonna get a snack and uh
you've been listening to life is short
i'm your host justin long with me as
always the short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan v monaco and senior producer on
this one and all of them is michelle
miesh lans audio engineer sergio
enriquez executive producer marshall
louis company name wandery
[Music]
respectful of deepak
oh that's true
i don't know what could we talk about um
that's both respectful and that's not
respectful the death the life and death
of boners that i mean it relates to what
he's saying
you their death is all around
it's part of life
you could talk about um how you've been
talking about doing meditation for years
but you never have uh-huh
yeah
oh you know what i should do my first
meditation this morning
and talk about the effects that i had on
me
you know because i have that new
meditation app
you